bill what was that um the star wars
story you met j.j abrams and you went up
to him and you said i want to do a voice
in star wars right and yeah and then you
did a voice not j no as jj called me and
said do you want to come in
i want to talk to you maybe doing a
thing on star wars right oh yeah sure
and they showed to me and i had no idea
it was bb-8 it's like the new r2d2 and
i did a voice
with my voice and i could tell the guys
in the room everybody was like
no
no
you were just like bill hater yeah it
was more like
was me doing this thing and they're
going out and then so we ended up doing
was months and months later jj called me
and said
we figured it out it's a talk box like
the peter frampton yeah talk box into an
ipad
so why don't you come in and do that
isn't it insulting they call you up tell
you to come in and then you do a voice
and they go no
i mean it happens all the time it does
well here's the voice actor this is what
ended up being the voice it was keep
away from the sinking fields in the
north you'll drown in the sand
that's you yeah i could tell you could
tell what's that sound if you knew you
would know that's him you
when i saw star wars